The cost of college is about $22,000. Some colleges are more expensive, and some
are less. But this is about the average price of college today. If tuition and
fees increase by 4.8% each year, how much would you expect to pay next year?
Take your time on this quiz. Think about if you have to add or subtract a
percentage to 100%. Also, be careful when you convert your percent to a decimal.
This is a pretty good problem for anyone out there in school. You could use this
problem to figure out about how much you would need to pay for school for a
year. Think about if you have to add or subtract the percentage to a 100. Also
be careful when you convert your percentage to a decimal. You can put your
00:00:37,526 --> 00:00:00,000
answer in this box here. Go ahead.
Good luck.